Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video
mi mancano i vecchi tempi eh Ciao a
tutti ragazzi su gotzing later e sono
svenuto Ho giocato un minuto eravamo
rimasti che ho trovato la seconda stanza
che effettivamente non ho capito che
poteri mi stia dando lanciafiamme Ah
sono mica questi Ah coi punti posso
comprare sta roba bellissimo Lancia
fuochi d'artificio subito lo compro Come
si compra più punti compresa e vuol dire
che io posso sparare le cose Vediamo Sto
male e non la sapevo sta roba Salve
lagna Allora in tutto sto casino Ho
capito che le torri ti sbloccano parti
della
chiesa del mausoleo non so come chiamare
sto posto quindi più vado avanti e più
mi sblocco porte per adesso siamo alla
seconda Volevo provare a vedere se
riuscivo a mascherare un pochettino
tutte le zone perché effettivamente io
sblocco le zone Ma non è che le guardo
per bene quindi facciamo che giochiamo
zona per zona adesso ne abbiamo
sbloccate due Ma quale Quali altre cose
posso prendere Scusate Ah con questo
posso volare Ali celestiale Minchia Ma
quanti punti c'ho ragazzi cioè Ah perché
si possono blocchi sbloccare un sacco di
robe No vabbè ma è incredibile cioè vai
sblocco i trampoli e con le ali è finita
Cioè faccio qualsiasi cosa posso Beh
vabbè la capra lavica va bene Ho un
miliardo di punti raga posso fare quello
che voglio una melanzana in bocca eh
tutto quello di cui hai bisogno 69 69
costavano non so se avete visto Eccolo
qua bene Non ho capito come faccio a
volare Ah premi più volte spazio mentre
sei in aria per volare vediamo
bellissimo posso planare forse è un po'
troppo in questo momento Vabbè poi nel
caso mi dovessero servire le prendo va
bene facciamo i fuochi d'artificio per
adesso e teniamo gli stivali da pioggia
le Crocs un punto costano le Crocs Va
bene Allora ragazzi l'obiettivo di
questo episodio è andare da Ikea
Buongiorno è fatta benissimo mancano le
polpette effettivamente quelle che è la
parte interessante di che è quella
Ragazzi c'è una scala là la vedo come si
fa a arrivare là aspetta ah da dietro
sto male ok Aspetta
mi sembra un po' eccessivo mettere la
rete elettrificata da Ikea non è che
siamo al Pentagono Eh però vabbè Ah ma
forse Ah
ma c'era il trick Scusate ragazzi non
sono molto esperto di giochi di capre
queste cose non le capisco
Si vede che non sono esperto i giochi di
Gabry Ecco c'è un Delivery Come hai
fatto a finire qua Come va la tua
giornata ragazzi c'è un precipizio fate
occhio
Vabbè cosa state facendo qua dentro ah
giocate a bowling sto male fai prima a
me
fa che è sta roba che risucchia Scusate
eh Secondo me ragazzi ci sono dei punti
che tu puoi raggiungere solo se sei più
piccolo Devo tornare più piccolo ragazzi
Eccoci qua Allora devo devo
rimpicciolirmi tutto quello che devo
farmi Ok Comunque raga l'olio è
terrificante cioè Eccoci Sono un po'
troppo piccolo forse mi sembra forse ho
esagerato un attimo
vado a farmi un panino Ragazzi arrivo Ah
eccoci qua ancora qua siamo posso uscire
da sto posto per favore E vabbè
ma tutto
andate a [ __ ] c'è una roba che
volteggia qua è una sfida bloccata
disponibile solo perché c'è il
multiplayer online visto cioè vabbè
Prima o poi ci giocherò anche a quello
Ah ragazzi incredibile e la melanzana
che bugga tutte le macchine perché se io
faccio così si bugga la macchina la
melanzana bagga le macchine in questo
gioco c'è un'isoletta carina eh quante
cose si scoprono quei bug hai visto
dovrei fuggire di qua vediamo se riesco
a fuggire con la melanzana Non lo so e
vedo
si fugge
c'è un gonfiabile bellissimo posso
andare qua sopra no vabbè c'è il parco
acquatico ci si scopre sempre qualcosa
anche dopo 3000 video sul mio canale
cioè questa cosa incredibile Comunque
vediamo se riesco a salire Come si fa a
salire eh a entrare nel parco così ma è
Parkour senza il biglietto me ne fotte
bellissimo Voglio la tartaruga
salvagente come on yes Ok let's go
scamone bellissimo che si era no tra
l'altro questo Ragazzi è la più grande
paura che uno dei parchi acquatici che
possa succedere davvero eh Lasciamo
perdere tanto ormai ho il mio salvagente
quindi una paura di niente Buon
compleanno Philip
non ha risposto nessuno no ma no Ma
poverino ha fili
Ragazzi c'è il compleanno di Philip
brutti figli di [ __ ] cosa fate qua
fuori uno specchio ti porto amici che
sono un casino qua adesso tutti contenti
buon compleanno pagliacci
coi regali che esplodono perché io
maschi questo che eseguiranno piroette
perfette zero su tre ma devo farlo
anch'io non ho capito insegnate a fare
le piroette che qua non riesco a
completare la missione sennò
Ah le devo girare io Ah ok a posto
Yes che grazie Minchia un tornado e la
Madonna
ok
ok va bene E questa roba continua senza
che ci posso fare
posso uscire da questo gioco è fatto
tutto a caso si capisce niente Ho creato
un tornado con le pirotte delle
ballerine che sta facendo casini e basta
Vabbè Ehm Boh È per questo che è un
invidia 3090 nel pc posso rubare L'auto
della polizia
c'è la melanzana mi ero dimenticato c'è
la polizia dentro Ciao ragazzi scusate
che c'ho la melanzana qua ma stiamo
scherzando hai sbloccato zoccoli pelosi
No veramente C'è un tizio con una lancia
gigante posso colpire la gente
bellissimo posso avere uno sfidante
qualsiasi No eccolo qua il mio sfidante
Ciao ragazzo
è morto c'è ancora il tornado che va in
giro ma tutto bene bellissimo questo
sarebbe sarebbe Alla ricerca di Nemo
solo che l'hanno chiamato Steve è il
titolo l'hanno messo si chiama dove
cazzo è Steve bellissimo c'è il
parapendio No vabbè dai ragazzi ma sto
male Vediamo se riesco a ficcarci in
volo di quelli incredibili Let's go
Madonna è bellissimo ma sto male eh però
non arrivo sulla cima della torre del 5G
sarebbe utile perché voglio vedere cosa
succede Ah forse arrivo fin qua
attenzione che potrebbe essere ottimo
perché così arriva la torre Attenzione
ci sono
Se riuscissi a mettere il turbo mentre
ho il parapendio sarebbe fighissimo
perché potrei arrivare veramente ovunque
però per adesso ci va bene così ma
chissà che cacchio c'è in cima qua se
non c'è niente me vi giuro spengo eh
Cioè veramente
Eccoci
e adesso mi danno fastidio
Porca vacca e quello ha scattato pure la
foto non pensavo che mi lanciassero le
mani mi possono arrestare quindi
non credo che siano così Ferrati sti
poliziotti Però vabbè Ah possono
arrestarmi sto male No io volevo andare
eh no C'ho la melanzana Sì non ti
conviene ti conviene arrestarmi in
macchina eh anche Joker era fuggito così
dalla macchina la polizia Vabbè ragazzi
Direi che posso concludere qua questo
episodio di goat Simulator abbiamo un
po' esplorato anche l'ultima parte non è
proprio l'ultima ossia l'ultima Sì più o
meno c'è anche tutta sta parte qua
ancora a vedere abbiamo visto un bel po'
di roba ma nel prossimo episodio se sono
ancora vivo perché non è detto aspetta
che
molto meglio di quanto pensassi molto
meglio di quanto pensassi se nel
prossimo episodio riesco Voglio provare
a vedere Arcore Monica voglio provare a
vedere se riesco a giocare anche in
multiplayer ragazzi prima di finire sto
gioco qua in tutto e per tutto questo è
un cinema posso metterci ci metto io il
film metto il film e concludo raga
Eccola l'ho trovata L'ho trovata
attenzione hai leccato Amore è un film
d'amore ragazzi mettiamo questo e poi
concludiamo perché secondo me merita vi
lascio col film ragazzi in chiusura vi
lascio il film
al prossimo video Ma cos'è
È tutto così Che palle
[Musica]